tout a commencé en 1997 avec le
protocole de kyoto
comment réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en donnant un prix au
carbone
le principal responsable de la pollution
atmosphérique voici les principales
régions où un système existe que ce soit
directement une taxe ou une bourse comme
c'est le cas au québec et en californie
dans cette bourse les entreprises les
plus polluantes doivent respecter des
plafonds celles qui émettent moins
peuvent vendre des droits d'émission à
celles qui polluent le plus en plus de
la taxe introduite aujourd'hui un
système de tarification existe déjà au
canada mais il est moins contraignant le
système québécois de marché du carbone
et plus englobant il englobe plus de
secteur est la grande différence avec le
système fédéral c'est qu'il a un plafond
d'émissions qui limite la quantité
absolue de gaz à effet de serre qui peut
être émises à partir du québec et avec
ce marché les pétrolières répercute les
coûts à la pompe les québécois qui paie
les sens plus cher qu'ailleurs au canada
paie donc une taxe sans le savoir si
cette taxe était vraiment connu on
serait que le prix du litre d'essence
sans les coûts pour le carbone se
seraient 500 de moins
un montant qui va continuer d'augmenter
c'est difficile de prévoir exactement de
combien mais je pense qu'on peut compter
sur du 10 15% d'augmentation par année
le québec champion de la taxation du
carbone alors que c'est aussi lui qui
aimait le moins neuf tonnes de co2 par
habitant et par an deux fois moins que
la moyenne canadienne et une taxe sur le
carbone peut aussi représenter un coût
politique
bon pour l'écologie bon pour l'économie
elle explique en partie la défaite au
fédéral des libéraux de stéphane dion en
et elle est aussi l'étincelle qui a
provoqué le mouvement des gilet jaune en
france ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal